that sounded great that sounded great
thank you
now of course we're going to go on to
this other scene where actually
uh you're this is later now after you're
trying to convince me to go on your
mission basically
and uh and he's resistant to all this
the interesting thing here is that um
you're trying to act like you know why
the ocean chose you but really
really you don't that's something you've
been trying to figure out from
from the early part of the movie is just
what was it about you
that made the ocean choose you you'd be
a hero
that's what you're all about right my
people didn't send me
the ocean did the ocean make sense
you're what eight
can't sail obvious choice
it chose me for a reason and you're
going to be meeting maui
who you've heard these stories about but
of course your grandmother said you know
he was a guy to watch out for and right
so you're kind of you're trying to
gather yourself up you're not sure what
to expect
i wish i could be the perfect daughter
but i come
back to the water no matter how
hard i try
my people beside me and when i think of
tomorrow there we
are
[Music]
and here we are with uh moana meeting
maui for the first time really
on your eye go ahead take it away mr a
thousand years you've been alone on this
island
you've lost your fish hook you've had
some rough times and you find this boat
and you don't know where it came from
but you've been on this rocky island
where a boat is a big deal now
you had no force to you know do anything
but now with a boat you got a way to get
off this thing
ah but you know what hey we'd never make
it past tikka not without my hook
then we'll get it we get your hook take
out the camera start the heart unless
you don't want to be miloid then we
gotta win at sea
hero to all
all right first we get my hook then save
the world
deal deal boat a boat
the gods have given me uh
maui shapeshifter demigod of the wind
and sea i
am moana of hero of men
what it's actually maui shapeshifter
demigod of the wind and sea
hero of men i interrupted uh from the
top hero of men go
so uh daughter of the chief
right i thought you stayed in the
village you know kissing babies and
things
hey hey hey i'm just trying to
understand why your people decided to
send um
how do i phrase this what's that you
okay listen let me tell you something
if the ocean is so smart why didn't it
just take the heart back to te fiti
itself why didn't it just bring me my
hook huh
i'll tell you why because the ocean's
straight up kooky dukes
but i'm sure it's not wrong about you no
you're the
chosen one that's right because it only
appears
after a human sacrifice
now come here kidding
why is so serious a knucks
a nuts
okay don't worry it's a lot farther down
than it looks when you were waddling yay
hide this guy
when the nights got cold who stole you
fire from down below
you're looking at him yo but does it
take away don't mess with maui when he's
on a breakaway and the tapestry here in
my skin
is a map of the victories i win look
where i've been i make everything happen
look at them in their
[Music]
what minds wonderful world you know
hey it's okay it's okay you're welcome
the tides of grass the ground oh that
was maui just messing around
i killed an eel i buried its guts
sprouted a tree now you got coconuts
what's the lesson what does it take away
don't mess with maui when he's on a
breakaway and the tapestry here in my
skin
oh what what is this thing
it's like it's kind of it's got two legs
which is
which is an unusual number um what's
it what's what's this furry stuff on top
wait a minute this is just a human
what is a human doing down here in the
realm of
monsters wait hey pick an eye babe it's
distracting when you go back and forth
like that just pick one
in the realm of monsters
wait a minute are you just trying to
make me talk about myself
because if so you you should have just
said so i would gladly talk about myself
do you mind if i do it in song form
little crab once
now i know i can be happy as a clam
because i'm beautiful
like a treasure from a sunken pirate
wreck
scrub the deck and make it look shiny
[Music]
what a terrible performance get the hook
you will die die die now it's time for
me to take apart
[Music]
who made you feel
[Music]
[Music]
me we talked a lot about crabs
and mollusks and i wanted to bring you
here from the moment you opened your
eyes this is a sacred place
a place of chiefs there will come a time
when you will stand on this peak and
place a stone on this mountain like i
did
like my father did and his father
and every chief that has ever been and
on that day
when you add your stone you will raise
this whole
island higher you are the future of our
people moana
and they are not out there they're right
here it's time to be who they need you
to be
you are the future of our people moana
and they are not out there they're right
here it's
time to be who they need you to be mom
when when uh grandmother says you gotta
go on this mission
uh there's a scene actually it's a
pantomime but uh mom
then when juan is packing up i gotta go
i gotta do this mission suddenly she
pulls up and there's mom in the door
like what's she gonna do and mom helps
her pack the stuff and kind of gives her
a hug
so mom even though she's been on dad's
side all this time and this kind of
supported dad she's
she's been much more empathetic to
moana's issues
the strength of her grandmother the
guidance and then the spirit
because even though her mother has to
respect and understand that uh
we have to abide by these rules her
spirit is like it is it's like
you should go yeah i believe in you and
you
sometimes who we wish we were
what we wish we could do
it's just not meant to be
it's just not meant to be it could have
been worse could have said it in front
of your dad
standing on a boat okay
consider extremes
consider its trees
he was a demigod of the wind and sea
a trickster a shape-shifter
who wielded a magical fishhook
and his name
was maui
that's great so what if we go on we do
you've been
told all our people's stories
but one what is this place
you really think our ancestors stayed
within the reef
what's in there
[Music]
what is in there the answer
but one day
someone will journey beyond our reef
find maui deliver him across the great
ocean to restore the
heart of te fiti
i know a girl from an island
she stands apart from the crowd
she loves the sea and her people
she makes her whole family proud
the people you love will change you
the things you have learned will guide
you
and nothing on earth can silence
the quiet voice still inside you
who are the people you
love will change you the things you have
learned will
guide you oh and you've come so far
more do you know who
you are
chief i'm telling you every storm this
roof leaks
no matter how many fronds we add oh
chief i'm telling you
every time this roof leaks no matter how
many fronds
chief it's your mother
aloha these are for you oh thank you
i'm shooting everyone so everyone's in
it uh
come here it's so good to see you it's
so good to meet you
good to meet you too she is amazing in
the movie
wait till you see her wait till you hear
her i know what you're thinking i go
through this all the time so for
everybody where's our
right there there's there's our this is
the number one camera right here those
are great right
they're beautiful thank you right now
she's like wow he's just
so like more handsome in person
there's one thing so when you see her in
the movie like you hear her in the movie
and it's like the first 10 15 minutes
you're like oh this is gonna be good
and then she starts singing it's mic
drive it's game over
yes
hello i'm great how are you meet your
dad
hi daughter spoiler i don't listen to
you much
how are you oh my gosh you look
[Music]
we designed beautiful character first i
know
look at you totally moana
thank you so gorgeous incredible
just envisioned grandma i you sound so
different
i know we tricked you she's a lot
younger yeah yeah yeah yeah
darling thank you for being my brother
oh pleasure
thank you for being my beautiful mukul
see you soon eh yes good luck with
everything you'll be
you're amazing
crushed in that pattern as she tried
pushing it down
but we can get it kind of under some of
those leaves so she's kind of hitting it
more from the stem
like you're saying yeah i mean i don't
know where the what's with the main okay
right
one post maui not available
i can rotate her uh her hand closer back
to her body so you don't see it yeah
that's what i was running just to
do that bring that tip so we see this
plane a little bit more and we
we mask it but once it's dropped in her
hand
books
is
all the way down to the actual
curves which is what this is
[Music]
signature yeah the same sure maui
before i chose
i love the way the the manta rays
interact with hollow yeah
beautiful you realize you're gonna have
to cover the whole scene yeah you're
locking yourself into
you've shown that all of that
what moana wants yeah and so this is a
good point when that character
is kind of leaving her yeah that's
nice
this is gonna get huge laughs
i'm
it's the serious
you